David up until now we've seen a good
deal of Romans and got some sense of
what Paul is arguing about justification
by faith about God's gracious gift of
forgiveness of sins and reconciliation
with him
Paul sense that the life of the
reconciled believer is being lived in
the the spirit that's a present reality
reality that one can when consents in
prayer and we've seen Paul wrestling
with the issue of the role of the law
and why it is the law can be objectively
the Torah we're talking about right the
Torah can be objectively good and holy
and true but from Paul's point of view
doesn't solve the problem of a
fundamental problem of human sin fear
which he takes to be a universal problem
so in some ways I guess Paul has has
provided us two or three solutions to
that problem of of sin God's gracious
act of forgiveness through the the death
of Christ and God's infusion of the
Spirit that somehow is transforming us
even though that transformation is not
yet complete so that he celebrated that
then at the energy separate and we noted
they the marvelous language in which he
does that celebration and that sort of
brings it brings to a halt that stage of
the argument and he turns to something
else now and I guess they have two
questions how would you describe that
something else and how does it fit with
all of the stuff that we had before I'm
much clearer around how you describe to
something else then on how it fits so
let's start with that then we'll work on
the fit together the something else is
how do we understand the place of Jewish
people of Israel in God's new economy
given the fact that when Paul looks
around not many of his fellow Jews have
become part of this in Christ community
that it's a predominantly a Gentile
community and yet God's promise seems
from the beginning to have been a
promise for all of Israel and and how
does it fit I think I do need your help
on this but I think that one way of
reading chapters 1 to 8 is to insist on
the absolute faithfulness of God that
what God promised to Abraham God has
enacted in Jesus Christ and and that
awed allness in
in Chapter five where what God doesn't
Adam he undoes for all in Jesus Christ
what we do and had him quiet God undoes
for all its that for all thing how is
God still God for all given the fact
that so many of the Jewish people seem
to have turned away and I think in some
ways gay this is a defense of God this
is a defense of God's faithfulness even
though the the empirical odds don't look
that good right now for Israel now I'd
certainly agree with that that a major
issue for Paul major theoretical issue
as well and a practical issue was given
his understanding of the gospel as is
God someone who changes exactly
you can't have God changed so part of
what it does in chapters 9 through 11 is
to show the places in Torah while Torah
already predicts that God will do this
in particular ways so that what you see
is not God's turning away but God's
total consistency with the plan rightly
understood okay so how does the argument
work well let me I think I think there
there are three moves to the argument
and let me just give give us all three
and then I'd love to have you circle
back and help me understand each the
first claim that that that Paul wants to
make is that God cannot be unfair that
it is God's choice who will move into
the state of redemption who will be
righteous and that in some important
ways it's not the role of humankind to
say to God alright you're not doing this
just Lea but his Gettys God who defines
justice not we and therefore by God's
very nature we can be sure that what God
does is faithful to and just I think
that's the first big argument the second
argument is that that from the beginning
if you read the Old Testament right if
you read the Hebrew Bible right you will
notice that God promises not to save
everybody but to save a remnant the time
after time in exile in the words of the
prophets what you see is God's promise
that to save a remnant of Israel is
still to save Israel and Paul believes
that their believes knows recognizes
that there is a remnant of Jewish people
himself included who are faithful to
this new promise in Jesus Christ and
therefore God has been loyal because God
as in the Exile has chosen a remnant to
be faithful but then finally in Chapter
11 he's not satisfied with that
he wants and here's where it gets
particularly complicated Paul wants to
claim that that God not only has not let
go of a remnant of Israel he wants to
claim that God has not let go of Israel
and that the promise finally is that
that at the end of the of the human
story which he thinks is not that far
away the Jews will be shamed by the
Gentiles faith into believing that
they'll look around and say ah they're
onto something I'd take it all back
Jesus Christ is the way let me join the
community right you know we've spoken a
time or two about Paul's reading of
Scripture yeah and about the ways in
which sometimes it's very strong but
from a modern point of view rather odd
right in the scripture the Abraham story
was separating Abraham's fidelity and
circumcision for something wouldn't it
never graduate Jewish region where the
person except Paul except right now in
Romans 9 through 11 it seems to me we
have maybe a two or three part reading
of Scripture a lot of which looks to be
traditionally Jewish yeah yeah in the
notion of election election good remnant
good and the remnant yeah yeah I mean
that's a strong thing even in the in the
progress in the nature and the notion
that part of Israel can be unfaithful
Israel's girl this is Deuteronomic
history so it's just the last part it's
the last couple hundred yeah see
eschatological part and it's Paul's
great belief as I read Romans what Paul
wants to claim is that the one God
intends to redeem all of humankind
through the one man Jesus Christ and his
weak reading of that is that means some
people believe from every nation his
strong reading is finally everybody
comes in and in eleven he's got to read
he wants to read the text in such a way
that the Gentiles shame the Jews into
believing yeah that's certainly the
argument of the surface yeah it's
analogous to the argument it seems to me
about about sin using the law in order
to create more seeing right right right
same sort of psychological acai colossal
amount
you know there's been a lot of
conversation about Romans 9 through 11
in the post holocaust period yes and
suggestions that Christians need to
rethink their technology in fundamental
ways and Paul has been called upon as a
resource yeah I had to do that what do
you make of those it's a two-part answer
because I think it's a it's a two-part
question I post-holocaust I was a I was
a really a little kid for the Holocaust
but so in for me it's actually more
growing up in a largely Jewish community
I'm I'm very reticent to head out with
the Jews for Jesus and bring them all in
because I think that undervalue is
what's still there in Paul which is the
Covenant still holds Torah is still
Torah God does not go back and God's
promises and I think it's it's
presumptuous for Christians in some ways
to go in and say ah yes but we've got
the promise in a way that you really
don't still come to it our way I think I
think that whether it's Paul or just my
reticence I have a very hard time with
kind of the mission to the Jews much
more than I do with mission to
secularists I have no problem whatsoever
were the secularists to ask me what I
believe I would testify without shame
when a Jew says what do you believe I'm
a little reticent because I want to say
your story is also part of the Covenant
and I'm I don't want to impose that on
you that's my answer to your first
question and I've entirely lost what the
other part of the question was but I
think you've combined okay good for me
it really was commenting on asking you
to comment on the way in which Christian
theologians have rested the problem of
Christian s exclusivity in one of the
ways in which I think many have done so
is to see a kind of two covenant
solution yeah that is God is faithful to
his covenant promises to Israel and you
seem to be sympathetic to I am
sympathetic at that the flip side of
that is and this is this is entirely
confessional a question of honesty that
that in some ways one of my favorite
theologians at Yale Hans Frye was a
converted Jew a philosopher and the
church I served in in California was a
converted Jew
I don't think they were unfaithful to
their tradition I don't think that they
never should have done that that somehow
that was a violation of their true
selves so I'm torn between my strong
sense that God is still God of both
covenants and my sense that it's it is
faithful to say what one believes and to
trust the Holy Spirit to use that in
different ways I mean it would use yeah
I'm sympathetic I think to your final
comment there I'm suspicious myself of a
two covenant solution at least as a
reading of Paul yeah as a reading of
Paul I think it's very dubious and one
of the things that's always struck me
about these chapters is the image he
uses at the very end to talk about the
relationship between Jews and Gentiles
the image of the vine yep quite
different from vine and branches imagery
that we get and here he does seem to be
talking to a Gentile audience it doesn't
be one of the places where it's its
clearest that the people he has in mind
at least at this stage of Romans I think
he's predominately Gentile actually yeah
and he's reminding them that all that
they are and all that they have in their
relationship with God is dependent upon
God's relationship with the people
absolutely I think for Paul there aren't
two because he doesn't have a notion of
an ongoing salvation history they don't
have son yeah but I think he thinks only
in terms of Israel yeah and what he sees
is and he doesn't use this language
either but he sees a new way of people
becoming part of the people of Israel
and it's the Gentiles who are being
converted
oh absolutely absolutely but I also
think that it he does have this hope
that at the end of end of time
Jews who don't recognize Christ as the
instrument of this spreading of God's
good news will do so yeah I agree with
that entirely I think the one thing you
can never do with Paul is underestimate
the centrality of Jesus Jesus is not
optional to this story for any human
being what that does for us in a
post-holocaust world I think is tricky
because with good reason a certain
reticence has been imposed upon us by
the disasters of history you know so
what we do pastoral a and
in terms of our relationship with other
the folk doesn't necessarily follow
exactly what it says scenario my exactly
then that's what I think when you take
some cues from weekend for all concerns
we can indeed and certainly one of the
things that he says at the end is this
this hope again you know he lives in
hope throughout Romans and his hope is
that all Israel will be saved clear
right in Romans 11:25 so that you might
not claim to be wiser than you are
brothers and sisters and that's always a
major major Rabanne word to hear I want
you to understand this mystery yeah that
the hard thing will come upon Israel but
at the end all Israel will be saved yeah
and that's the hope in which he lives
yeah and again we have a conclusion here
in a bit of the doxology old the depths
of the riches and the wisdom and the
knowledge of God how unsearchable his
judgments how inscrutable his ways for
to him and through him and to him are
all things to him be glory forever which
is not a bad way to end the question
about Jews and Christians indeed yeah